y'a moyen de se tuer d'ici dix jours
enfoncez serbe 4 1
allez on se dira
nier les officiers sont de niveau 3
commun
où les efforts johnson je crois pas que
ce soit une très bonne idée oui c'est le
fun pas raisonnable j'essaie de te
sauver la vie vous avez pu vous évader
du labyrinthe mais vous ne tiendrez pas
une journée sur la terre brûlée les
fondus vous diront si les éléments ne
font pas thomas tu dois me faire
confiance je veux que votre bien et rien
d'autre ah ouais parce que oui qui était
bon c'est ça désolé mais tu es de
franchira pas cette forte
ouais
comment
du coup la dépêche
arrêté le palais dealer principal visé
n'est pas possible